[Music]
let's go to uh kristen in columbus ohio
what's up kristin
hi john how are you i am
i was gonna say dancing on the ceiling
but
lionel richie owns that line so i'm just
hanging out here what's up
um so i'm calling because i have a
daughter who will be 18 on friday
congratulations and may the force be
with you
and she suffers from pretty extreme
anxiety in all areas cool social
um
anxiety all of it yeah
so
she's getting ready to graduate high
school
and go off to college in the fall and
she is going away to school away from
home
and i'm looking for some strategies the
best way to help her deal with the
anxiety as she transitions into this
next life phase i love it great
questions all right i'm gonna ask you a
few quick questions okay
sure um question number one
where did she
learn this
is there somebody in your home that
struggles with anxiety do you wrestle
with it where did she pick that up as a
coping speaker dad and i have struggled
with anxiety and depression okay okay
um
what does it look like for her
when she's when she spun out what is
that what does that look like
she will get very angry um very
emotional
break out in tears
sometimes emotionally shut down it's
kind of a variety but it's usually an
extreme shutdown don't want to deal with
it or
yell lash out get angry cry okay kind of
those extremes where did she
how many of those behaviors are from
home too
and again this isn't an indictment i'm
just trying to get a full picture of of
her oh no absolutely um
i cry pretty easily okay um
i cried gas station commercials so i'm
with you
and there's been
a significant amount of yelling in the
home over the years okay all right
does she know have you and your husband
individually not together because that
can be overwhelming have the two of you
ever taken her out
and just said hey here's my story here's
my journey with anxiety with depression
yes how did that go
she
gets pretty defensive okay and reacts
more like you don't understand what i'm
going through okay it's different from
me she's 17. that's right i mean yeah
that's exactly yeah yeah that's
developmentally appropriate response
hey i've been there too i've seen a cute
boy too you don't understand yeah okay
all right
so see your old half-balding dad with
the rim like he used to be really
handsome back in anyway but yeah that's
that's that's appropriate so
um has your husband done that
he has um
and again
i love him he's supportive he's an
all-in dad but we do approach it i think
very differently okay and
he
is more of a
i'll talk to her
she'll get through it
i don't want to add to the stress by
calling out the behavior
so i don't want to say it's an avoidance
type of behavior but his is more of i'll
talk through it with her
and
give her my advice and then we'll see if
it changes
all right so
um you may have if you listen to the
show for any length of time you may have
heard me tell the story but i was doing
a practicum with a
child psychologist and
i had a young son and i was asking him
hey what what uh
what are some things i could tell my son
we had just dealt with a really messy
issue
with the youngster and
the young kid said some really awful
things about women and he was like the
kid was four so clearly he picked this
up and i have i had a young son too and
so i was using this kid as a proxy for
my own kid and i said what are you
supposed to tell a kid to help him like
respect women and he said that dr gomez
smiled at me and he said
and you can tell them anything you want
they're not going to listen to you if
you want them to treat your wife right
um if you want him to respect women then
treat your wife right because kids
here's the magic quote kids don't listen
to you they watch you
and so y'all can call out your
daughter's behaviors all day long
don't act like that i can't believe
you're throwing this temper tantrum you
don't talk like that to people in this
house you can do that all day long but
if the house is filled with chaos or
anxiety or yelling
that speaks that is the road map that
your daughter has been given to how to
handle stress and how to handle hard
things and so
often when people say how do i deal with
the anxiety how my kids got anxiety what
can i do for them i tell them fix your
marriage
and
that's usually where a lot of that stuff
starts not always there's there's
medical issues all kind of stuff but
you your your willingness to be honest
is really helpful here so let me fast
forward to i spent 20 years 17 years i
don't know how a long time almost two
decades working with college kids in
this exact world right so
tell me about her academic success
she's almost a straight a student um
she i think she's gotten one a minus in
her four years of high school how dare
her what a failure did she cry over did
she weep
she's
no but she brings it up every so often
of i don't have a perfect record because
of this do you have other kids and
i have a son who's two years older
what is his
how are his grades
he's more of a b-plus student okay so
and his was i'll do the best i can if
it's not an a i'm okay with it okay
a lot of you he was more accepting a lot
of kids with anxiety
are performers
they have an a very attentive radar for
other people watching out for what
they're doing right and wrong
and either they are trying to
control other people's emotions in the
house because that's one of the jobs
they've been given for instance hey
don't say that dad's gonna get really
mad
or you know your father doesn't like
whatever or mom loses her crap when this
happens so don't dig and so kids feel
like it's my job to perform in whatever
way so that mom and dad
don't have to have their outbursts
and that
rattles a kid's body it makes kids
anxious makes adults anxious right when
they're responsible for their bosses or
for their spouse's behaviors right so
often straight a's and one of the
challenges with academics is straight
a's looks like my kid's successful
but really they have learned if i can do
this it avoids that
right and often this is gonna sound
bonkers kids who get into drugs kids who
get into
sleeping around a lot kids who get into
straight a's
the behaviors are different but the
intent is the same
i need connection i need somebody to see
me i need to avoid right they're all
avoidant if i get straight a's mom and
dad leave me alone so is her is that her
and again i'm using part of this to
teach to the audience too does that is
that her is straight a's keep y'all off
her back or is that where she finds
esteem or she just a really smart kid
who loves cranking it out
i think she's really smart and i think
that's where she finds her self-esteem
okay okay so she's got a picture of
success here okay so yeah
i'll give you some hard truths and some
reality truths is that cool yeah what is
um give me a picture of her college uh
fancy pants private school fancy pants
state school like what is she is she
leaving the state where's she going you
don't tell me the name of the school
no it's a four-year private school it's
a catholic university
and it's as far on the east
coast of ohio the east end of ohio she
can get without getting out of the state
so she's doing a classic seven-year-old
running away which is i'm running away
all the way to the backyard right okay
and um
she
again did get some pretty significant
scholarships for this particular school
okay um but
it yeah that's what it is it's a a
catholic faith-based university about
two and a half hours from home okay
so
an anxious and
often not always but often depressed
brain is a in a child especially is a
disconnected brain
so if i'm sending my kid two hours away
i'm going to a make and she's got
clinically diagnosed anxiety clinically
diagnosed depression right this isn't
just she stresses out but she is this is
a challenge
a
for sure i'm gonna check with the
disability students disabilities office
make sure she's got the report the
support resources she needs
i'm making sure she's got somebody to
call if things get heavy
the second thing is
i am as a parent and this can be the
helicopter i don't care i will make sure
that she is at least plugged in with the
student counseling center now they can't
call you they can't tell you unless
she's suicidal which hopefully she never
gets there she can't they can't tell you
she's going to sessions they can't do
any of that stuff okay but
making sure there's a contact and when i
worked in in those positions i would get
emails from parents and i would forward
them on to the counseling center and the
counseling center proactively reaches
out to the student so it is not weird or
odd or anything like that for parents to
reach out and say my kids struggled with
this forever i want to put them on your
radar on day one that's actually really
helpful for the school okay
even for the residence life program if
you want to have that conversation
i will tell you
picking a kid up from everything they
know and setting them in a brand new
environment is tough their brain is
going to say hey whoa we're super
disconnected now
and so
really encouraging her
really encouraging her to get plugged in
with student activities whether that's
with clubs and organizations or whatever
encourage encourage encourage even if
it's
you don't you've got to get involved in
two things here or i'm not sending any
more money for whatever right and that's
what i would do with my kids i would
make a financial incentive you have to
get plugged in with with future
nursing association of america or the
future medical students or future
engineers or whatever she's going to do
you got to get involved in that group or
my money stops because i know the
psychology you've got to get involved in
something
and here's the last one
no matter what
don't let her live by herself in a
private room especially the first year
especially she got to have a roommate
here's why
if you have a private room the only
reason to leave your room
is to leave the building
and there's not what i call accidental
community you have to run into people
who are using the bathroom who are
coming and going you have to learn to
manage that
and that person even if they're annoying
and they drive you crazy
that person becomes an anchor for you or
at least gives you something to talk
about to somebody else
but that person becomes a checkpoint hey
where were you last night in that kind
of
uh accountability that kind of hey
what's up hey how's it going what's up
and my i was a loudmouth brash
long-haired idiot who was into punk rock
and metal from houston and my roommate
was a
short
kind
theater major from rural kansas
you could not have picked two more crazy
random people
and ultimately he was in my wedding and
i was in his and he is the guy who takes
care of my investments now out in
colorado spring so and him and i have he
came and stayed with me last year so all
i have to say is it's there's a lot of
decisions to be made as you as you move
into these relationships but
under no circumstances would i send a
kid who i know has clinical anxiety and
depression and say you should live by
yourself in a box two and a half hours
away and deal with the academic stress
and rigor alone
that's a recipe for disaster okay i
don't know she's self-aware enough that
she even said that she said i'd love to
have a private room but i know i need to
have a roommate beautiful beautiful
beautiful that's awesome
all right so here's the last thing i
want to recommend
i want you
to not talk about her anxiety or
depression i want you to talk about
man
you know i want you to take her out and
just have mom's breakfast mom's lunch
mom's dinner
and until she leaves i want you to make
once a week thing i've recommended this
to parents for years once a week you got
to come out for me for a meal i'll take
you to school or whatever you'll go to
school on your own i don't know whatever
it is saturday mornings or whatever or
our time
and i'm going to tell you some things i
wish i had done differently and we're
going to talk about you mom
you know what i wish i hadn't yelled so
much in the house
i avoided my anxiety for a long long
time i wish i hadn't done that
i'm sorry
like i'm really working on my yelling
and i'm actually starting to see a
counselor now if i don't if i told you
that but i'm trying to do that now
i want you to spend some time talking
about you telling stories about when you
were in college when you were young when
you had kids when you were scared and
all those things here's what it's going
to do it's going to humanize your
journey we call it social norming she's
going to realize she's not crazy that
her experiences
other people have had them
and she's gonna build a connection with
you in a relationship with you that
hopefully will translate into a once a
week you'll write a letter when she's in
college you will connect with her in
college et cetera you'll keep this line
open not an everyday texting mom about
everything line but a communication line
so she's gonna be way out there but
she's gonna have an anchor point at home
and it's not an anchor point on you
better get your crep it's an anchor
point on i love you and i've been there
too
very few things heal an anxious heart
like
i love you i'm with you and i've been
there too